to me there's there's a lot of kind of
you know love and compassion driven by
extreme psychotic fear and I was very
alarmed
um at how many vaccine injuries I was
hearing about particularly the
myocarditis in in younger boys younger
men um the heart inflammation and the
absolute gaslighting on that specific
topic and so for me as a journalist at
that point that was a step way too far
but what's been shocking is it was
mainstream media but also alternative
media that was kind of propping up this
this narrative we have caused
irreparable harm in public trust in
people's Health we have destroyed the
reliability of these institutions we
have actively harmed
Untold numbers of people particularly
young men and women the complete failure
on the part of Public Health to be
honest about again who this product was
for and who had benefited it was
completely Reckless
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest today is very
successful young journalist RAV Aurora
welcome to trigonometry hey it's great
to be here it's great to be traveling in
the UK seeing some new culture I mean
that is one way of putting it mate yeah
he was in Cardiff made so what culture
he saw I don't know but anyway it's fun
yeah little cousins who are you know
bred from the same class same kind of
Indian background but different accents
certain cultural similarities but still
some differences in terms of just
communication and outlook on life it's
very very interesting to see the
differences yeah well it's interesting
going over to the us as well and because
we all assume that because we speak the
same language the culture is the same
actually is very very different in both
countries uh but before we we get to the
stuff we wanted to talk with you about
tell everybody a little bit more about
your background who are you how are you
where you are what's been your journey
through life so it brings you to be
sitting here yeah yeah so graduated from
high school in 2019 didn't know what the
[__] I was doing afterwards didn't have
a clear plan I was always kind of all
over the place kind of ADHD kid all
these big ideas and having a very strong
imagination but not having a firm
grounding of who I am and what I want to
do I was into hip-hop music I was into
certain kind of literary genres like
you know reading certain kinds of books
I was into philosophy
um but that was kind of it I was also
into political philosophy and kind of
paying attention to what was happening
in the culture
uh but then it was 2020 when George
Floyd happened tragic incident and then
the BLM uprisings the riots protests and
all the the racial Consciousness that
was you know growing after that then I
published a viral article in the New
York Post it was kind of my first entry
into journalism about the fallacies of
white privilege and the toxicity of
identity politics and that piece I was
talking about my background as an ethnic
minority who has experienced racism
growing up when I was very very young
and how I view a lot of the identity
politics discourse as an extension of
that kind of in this positive sort of
misleading kind of liberal light but
actually reinforcing certain kinds of
stereotypes and views on Race that I
think are actually backwards and so when
I started that that just kind of opened
up this new world for me to explore
these new ideas and then I wrote another
article about BLM I was very much
interested in policing and criminal
justice and so that got me through to
doing some reporting virtually on what
was happening in Minneapolis after
George Floyd the massive uptake in
homicides and how the media wasn't
covering that at all and then the
overall
Nationwide homicide increase in the
United States that was kind of one of my
Niche topics
um and then yeah that just became
something that I was exploring in the
New York Post and Colette in many of
these places criminal justice race
issues some of the gender stuff as well
um particularly I was looking at
differences in outcomes between you know
quote-unquote privileged white people
and and ethnic minorities and finding
across the board that this simplistic
narratives of white supremacy or
systemic racism were not actually in
line with the data in places like the
U.S where you have ethnic female groups
out earning uh white men now over the
past couple of years like you know women
from Pakistan Lebanon India Thailand you
know now having larger earnings compared
to white men and this kind of breaking
down these simplistic intersectionality
you know ideas and whatnot so that was
going on for a couple years and then
covet happened or covet was already
going on I remember that
yeah and I was not paying attention at
all to what was happening with kovid
like you know cases are rising cases are
falling I knew that I was not at any
kind of grave risk and most of my family
members were were fine
um but then this is kind of how the the
new phase of Journalism started during
the vaccine mandates which we can we can
talk about that suddenly when the
Mandate started being enforced for the
covet vaccines
that suddenly for me was this big
Awakening on what was really going on
um and that kind of led to my current
journalistic interests in Pharma and uh
you know Health policy the FDA the CDC
and misinformation surrounding our
health that's kind of the the focus
these days and you've launched a podcast
with Dr Jay batacara who's a former
guest of us who we're big fans of uh but
let's talk about vaccine mandates
because one of the things that's
interesting to me is we obviously have a
global audience there's people all over
the United States the UK and the rest of
the anglosphere and Beyond and whenever
you talk about anything to do with covid
we all assume that everybody else had
the same experience but actually that's
completely untrue I mean we have
Canadian fans who are still writing into
us and telling us about restrictions
that they're still having to put up with
in Canada uh whereas in many other
countries are obviously it's completely
over and that was the case throughout
the pandemic so when you talk about
vaccine mandates where are you talking
about and what actually was happening
yeah so I was in Canada so that explains
it that explains all of it yeah you
still got a bank account I do I do
recently I actually heard of someone who
who actually also had their account
Frozen during the Trekkers protest which
is very scary and very ominous
um no if you've got the right opinions
Yeah well yeah exactly
um so I'm about an hour away from
Vancouver and this is August in
September of 2021 when the vaccine
mandates were being introduced and
suddenly at that time couldn't go to
weddings large gatherings
um certain restaurants but most
importantly in most
um for me most troublingly was not being
able to exercise at a gym for some
period of time and and I was actually
Lucky in the sense that uh the gym that
I go to the the owner
um was actually not exactly following
all of the ludicrous Public Health
degrees so he kind of kept things going
but those were the mandates being shoved
down her throats was you can't go to a
gym can't go to certain restaurants or
Gatherings can't play certain
Recreational Sports if you're not
vaccinated and at that point just
completely with with an open mind open
eyes looking at the data at that point
like okay is this something that I need
is this safe and effective is this
something that's going to help me and
Grandma and Grandpa and the conclusion
at that time was Grandma and Grandpa you
know get the shots you know their obese
have certain health issues but for me it
was like it makes absolutely no sense at
that point to get vaccinated given how
young I am given also at that point some
of the confusing but and kind of unknown
but alarming signals on on heart
inflammation myocarditis so I decided
not to get the shots and as a result I
couldn't leave the country couldn't
travel to the US the UK uh we could
visit relatives in India we were just
kind of landlocked and Frozen because of
these vaccine mandates that you know
these vaccines weren't stopping you know
the transmission it didn't make sense to
have these border restrictions when the
virus was not isolated in certain
countries versus others it was a global
pandemic and the vaccines weren't
stopping transmission yet this was kind
of the The Narrative and if you looked
um there's some reporting done later in
with Barry Weiss in on on her sub stack
revealing kind of how this happened it
was all very telling about how this was
enforced like the Canadian government if
you look at some of the behind the
scenes emails that were were leaked
um in in
um there's some good reporting in the
Free Press with Barry Weiss it showed
that the know the health Minister the
transportation Minister like they were
they were all operating from
um we want to impose vaccine mandates
and we need to find some data to justify
it if you look at the emails like hey
what's the data on how vaccines could
could help with stopping the spread of
covid like they started from that place
rather than what should have been the
case was here's a really effective
vaccine that could stop transmission now
let's you know it still wouldn't make
sense but they were operating from this
Narrative of this is what we have to
enforce and we need compliance and so
for me as a journalist at that point
that was a step way too far and it
didn't make sense for me didn't make
sense for my brother at that point to
you know get the vaccine then I started
to go deeper and deeper into what was
going on and I was very alarmed
um at how many vaccine injuries I was
hearing about particularly the
myocarditis in in younger boys younger
men the heart inflammation and the
absolute gaslighting on that specific
topic I mean real cases of vaccine
injuries people you know young people
and older people as well and I can maybe
share one example
um on my sub stack of a 38 year old law
enforcement member in in my area also of
South Asian background who after his
second Pfizer shot almost died due to
the the adverse cardiac impact of the
vaccine and thankfully's girlfriend
called the ambulance because he thought
he was going to be fine or he ate
something wrong but ambulance arrived
um his heart his heart rate was
something crazy like 186 or something
crazy like that went to the hospital got
immediate care it was from the vaccine
um the cardiologist said but for someone
like him and there's many many cases
like this didn't need the vaccine you
know healthy guy in his case very very
fit exercising at a gym but the Mandate
the top-down mandate from the Trudeau
government was all federally regulated
Industries all people working for the
government including law enforcement had
to get the shots
um and that's you know in the U.S that's
early on first where we were hearing
about some of the the vaccine injuries
and the myocarditis signals was from the
military at first which implemented the
the vaccine mandates because you know
they're they're responding to Global
threats that potentially have to fight
and a lot of things are on the line we
were getting a lot of stories about the
myocarditis from them because they're I
mean not surprisingly in retrospect
predominantly healthy younger you know
male individuals serving in the military
and so when I started writing about this
um when we can I guess get into some of
the the suppression so I wanted to write
about
um these stories
um about hearing about these vaccine
injuries and being like hey these are
real issues and they're not being
covered in the New York Times or CNN
there's not adequate coverage
um and obviously covet is still you know
a real threat and we could talk about
that about
you know how the the public was kind of
misled on kind of who was at risk but
there were cases of vaccine injuries and
at the time for me again as someone who
you know still has like an open mind on
you know whatever's going on at that
point
August September October of 2021 I was
hearing about more cases of vaccine
injuries than people dying from covid in
my area I was hearing about
multiple young males especially who were
ending up hospitalized or ending up with
you know myocarditis you know doesn't
mean that people weren't dying from
covid you know that was another issue
but there was this very real issue that
I wanted to cover as a journalist who
previously has kind of covered these
other issues that aren't getting enough
you know attention you know whether it's
the you know the success of ethnic
minorities in the west or whether it's
the you know the the utter you know
neglect of the the the inner city
homicidal violence in places like
Minneapolis and Philadelphia
um and when I started pitching these
stories to Publications that I was
writing for which I'm not going to name
for a number of reasons but when I was
pitching these stories about are they
Publications we would have heard of oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah and
what would what would they say in
response yeah so and this was just so
shocking to me that this is the response
that I was getting it was time and time
again it was we are a pro-vaccine
publication we're not going to publish
this kind of reporting
um our newspaper our publication
encourages vaccination this may promote
anti-vaxxist area it may promote vaccine
hesitancy to actually write about these
cases
um you know this may endanger people
this may you know disincentivize people
to get vaccinated I mean those are the
responses from you have this in writing
from them yeah so this is on my yeah
yeah so I quoted them on my sub stack
um how mainstream and alternative media
Outlets suppress my Copa journalism
that's on the illusion of consensus with
Dr J where I've outlined specifically
but that's exactly what I was hearing
from
not only editors that I didn't know but
editors that I had relationships with
and editors who previously had published
my work dissenting from the mainstream
views on Race gender policing criminal
justice identity politics this was kind
of a line too far from them and that for
me was like oh wow like I thought I'd
already crossed the line I thought I was
already you know uncancelable already
had taken the you know the the cancel
culture Kool-Aid um but this time it was
like no no this is a line we can't cross
this is something that we're not going
to cover because we're a pro-vaccine
publication and we're not going to
promote this and that's what's kind of
led to my migration on substack and
being independent which wasn't preferred
initially because I again I've very
scatterbrained I have a lot of ideas and
I kind of like being in a collaborative
setting and getting to write for you
know an editor or a publication but for
someone like me who deeply cares about
the truth and wants to report on issues
that I think are important and are not
being adequately represented in
mainstream media that moment right there
you know we're not going to publish this
because it goes against the narrative
that then I was like okay I'm out and
and there were opportunities for many of
these places to still
um write about identity politics and
whatnot but I was like no no this is I
want to follow the truth and I want to
go where I want to go and if you're not
happy with that then I'll kind of go on
my own even if that means that I'll
sacrifice you know financially you know
there's certain costs I'll have to bear
but that's kind of where I want to go
afterwards and what do you think that
actually says about the mainstream media
that you can present a well-researched
piece of data and a well written because
I read your substances they're very well
written piece of Journalism and you
don't get accepted anywhere what did I
actually say about the media that we
have at the moment yeah well what's been
shocking is it was mainstream media but
also alternative media that was kind of
propping up this this narrative on you
know vaccines being safe and effective
for everyone and they're not being any
kind of downside or the downside you
know is Trivial it doesn't matter you
know that you know it begs the question
of what you know what's leading to that
I mean what are the biases what are the
perverse incentives and financial
interests at many of these places I mean
well you said it yourself I mean if if
your definition of your organization is
that you're a pro-vaccine publication
that's what they said I I mean I don't
see how that conflicts with reporting
that highlights some issues with
vaccines because surely you'd want the
public to be informed about the entire
information about something like that
wouldn't you yeah well yeah that's what
you would expect and that's been one of
the major problems with public health
over the past couple years right has
been
not not being transparent but actively
gaslighting the public on what's really
going on with who's at risk for covid
for example I mean in retrospect but
this was known you know over the past
couple of years
you know a few months into the pandemic
that kovid was a serious problem for
over overwhelmingly elderly and obese
and immunocompromised people
everyone other than that people like
myself people like yourself assuming you
don't have assuming you're not dying
tomorrow hopefully not
um it it was not the level of problem
that it was being portrayed in the media
absolutely not
um but the narrative always was you know
you have to get the vaccine this was
this is a big risk for everyone not just
elderly people and obviously you know
taking the vaccine for you know
protecting other people as well
um I mean that that alone in retrospect
and this is part of my collaboration
with Dr Jay bharacharya is looking at
some of these things
um and seeing that you know we've known
for throughout the pandemic you know a
few months in that the infection
fatality rate was something like point
zero two percent right Dr J was
authoring some of these studies early on
and looking at you know what actually is
the death rate for covid and in the
media you were hearing these grossly
exaggerated figures one percent two
percent or zero point five percent
infection fatality rate but people like
Jay and Dr John unities Dr Martin cold
or if the whole Great Barrington
declaration they were showing that
you know this is again overwhelmingly a
risk for for certain groups but not for
everyone else for everyone else it's
it's not this great big threat that is
being posed in the media and then the
vaccines come along and then the
gaslighting on vaccine injuries and
who's really
um uh you know who's really going to
benefit from this pharmaceutical product
um that you know
for me as someone who
prior to that point you know was getting
every vaccine you know was listening to
my doctor it was like whoa whoa I
thought you know my doctor I thought
people in lab coats who have degrees in
epidemiology and Immunology that I don't
have are to be absolutely trusted right
because I don't know anything I don't
you know grade 12 biology was a
nightmare I actually failed grade 12
biology probably shouldn't be announcing
that
but I I did not have a good time with
that class but
um but but as someone who does not have
that experience I it's it's and this is
you know some of the points that people
have made
um in opposition to some of the
contrarianism is that you want to
default to The Experts right you want to
believe the experts because they
actually know what they're talking about
whereas I don't have a degree in
epidemiology
um but one of the Fatal problems that
um people in mainstream media and some
people and alternative media have made
is is thinking that
the mainstream experts actually
converged on some foundational core
principles on the pandemic when they
absolutely did not right the difference
between Dr Eric topel Nicholas
christakis or Peter Hotes and Dr Jay
bhattacharya and Martin koldorf is
absolutely massive they fundamentally
disagree on the core points on vaccine
safety on vaccine Effectiveness on who's
actually at risk they fundamentally
disagree on some of these main points
yet there's this assumption that the
mainstream scientists they have one view
everyone else's quacks and that's what's
led to a lot of the censorship which we
can talk about but that kind of Illusion
of consensus which is the the title of
our our sub stack
um Dr Jay and I that's what's been such
a pernicious force and Awakening to that
has been such a massive lesson for me is
like
you know these people that I trusted so
much in before in purveying the
objective truth on what to do with my
health and my body actually were wrong
about some very you know critical facts
on again the vaccine side effects on on
covid
um uh you know the death rates for
Covenant who's actually being
hospitalized and and that that's kind of
Greater informed my perspective on
institutions and who to trust now
because there's been so much
manipulation and gaslighting on these
very core topics so there's a lot to
unpack there a lot let's talk about
vaccine injuries because to me part of
the problem is
it's become politicized so I spent far
too much time on Twitter and it seems
that every time a an athlete and I'm a
sports fan has a heart attack now that
is something that happened infrequently
but it has happened I remember several
athletes several soccer players have
died had a heart attack on the pitch
mark Vivian foe being a prime example a
few well about 20 years ago now check
Toyota
Etc had the same thing this isn't an
unknown phenomena now to someone like
myself it seems to be happening more and
more the problem is is that it's been
politicized so some people want to see
everything is a vaccine and some people
were saying well actually this could be
covered we don't know if the covert
virus actually damages the heart so
let's get into that sure yeah what do we
actually know yeah so we we do know that
for especially men under the age of 40
it's very it's very clear now but it's
also clear for you know people up to 50
60 you know and we can debate that but
it's very clear at least for men under
the age of 40 or 50 the risk of
myocarditis is far higher from the
vaccine than from covid at the
population level this is kind of the big
gas lighting is like well no you know
the covid causes higher rates of
myocarditis than the vaccine does and
that's kind of true on a population
level but that's not how you do medicine
right you don't you know I don't judge
whether to get the vaccine based on
overall on a population level they're
potentially being higher myocardial
right if there's 13 of the public that
have diabetes we don't treat you for
diabetes yeah yeah exactly and there's
some interesting distinctions that
cardiologists like Dr Anish Koka who
runs a Cardiology clinic in Philadelphia
have made between myocarditis from covid
which is very very different and
presents very differently than
myocarditis from the vaccine really I
didn't know that yeah well because
myocarditis from the vaccine is
occurring to very different people than
myocarditis from covet and I'm I'm not
going to go into the nitty-gritty of
what um the differences are but to put
it kind of Simply it's the people
getting myocarditis from covid you know
their pneumonia lung issues multiple
comorbidities there might be on death's
door serious issues going on with them
and then they also present you know
elevated troponin levels or other
markers of cardiac injury on top of
everything else going on right so that's
you know people in their 70s or 80s you
know they catch covid they're obese they
have all these conditions and now
they're having hard problems too right
that is fundamentally very different
from myocarditis from the vaccine which
overwhelmingly happens and you know it's
it's hard to know what exactly the risks
are and there's some interesting nuances
are interesting nuances there that we
can pick apart but it's it's
myocarditis from the vaccine is
happening to healthy people who have
very little to benefit from the vaccine
people like myself right young males and
in terms of you know the uptick in
myocarditis that's something that I've
been
very carefully tracking and and I wish I
had kind of a bigger platform you know
like the New York Times or CNN to talk
about this um because it's very very
alarming
um or you know early on I was tracking
different countries that have databases
on on myocarditis rates year after year
countries like this on my sub stack
France Germany uh Sweden
Israel as well as some U.S hospitals
show massive upticks in myocarditis
cases in 2021 not 2020. so places like
France and Germany saw 50 to 70 50 to 75
increases in myocarditis cases in 2021
okay Sweden also massive Optics uh like
I said some hospitals in the U.S that
have also tracked this and you talk to
any cardiologist and I've interviewed
you know many of them they just
anecdotally saw you know big upticks in
you know younger patients coming in with
heart issues and so that I mean that's
just indisputable that that was
happening there's one study that was
published in the scientific uh Journal
uh nature and that that I think that is
one of the most interesting data points
which showed this was MIT researchers
and Dr retzif Levy led the study and he
tracked
um 911 calls
um before and after and during the
distribution of the vaccine because
Israel keeps a close database on on on
health problems and on 911 calls and he
found just just you know just very very
clear alarming correlations in these are
myocarditis cases happening in Israel
and then vaccines are distributed and
then sudden spike in 9-1-1 calls for
acute cardiovascular events this is all
peer-reviewed published in nature you
have the first vaccine dose and the
second vaccine dose and you see massive
upticks in people calling in for cardiac
arrest acute coronary syndrome acute
myocardial injuries people coming in
with chest pains like massive uptick and
and then there's been all this
oppositional response to the study well
oh it's just correlation well it could
have been something else it's like dude
it's it's right there in the data this
was not happening before and obviously
correlation is not causation but when
it's that crystal clear right vaccines
are pushed you know to the Israeli
public and then massive uptakes in
people calling calling in for acute
cardiovascular issues I mean that you
know I look at facts like that that and
my sort of
um objective kind of
um sober-minded side does not want to
really believe that and wants to kind of
reject that like there must be something
wrong with that but if that is true
which it is it's like we have caused
irreparable harm in public trust in
people's Health we have destroyed the
reliability of these institutions we
have actively I mean putting aside you
know social media and the political
discourse we have actively harmed Untold
numbers of people particularly young men
and women with this vaccine very very
clear that they did not need the vaccine
and they got it because the FDA the CDC
um big Pharma you know governments in
Canada the US and the UK push these
shots based on eua emergency use
authorization approval cutting corners
and not actually being honest about who
this product is for and where it
arguably makes sense right it was never
that only elderly people should get it
and here are the risks and here are the
unknowns but it was always everyone
should get this thing young people
included and not only dose one dose two
dose three but in the US right now
um the recommendation as of a few months
ago I'm sure it's still the same it was
to get every
um individual the bivalent booster shot
which is a shot number four or shot
number five it depends on how you count
it but everyone and they moved it down
to six months old you're six months old
should get their fourth or fifth booster
shot like it makes no sense at all and
now the uptake is very low too right the
people getting their fourth or fifth
shots is like five ten percent it's very
very low and among young people it's
basically zero but this is what they're
actively pushing and that to me is just
you know incredibly just you know
offensive to us as people like we want
to care about our bodies and we want to
be very careful about you know being
healthy and about you know living a long
healthy happy life but what's happened
over the past couple of years has been
an absolute attack on our own autonomy
and our own personal god-given health
that we you know we only have one shot
at this right and if you're Mass
recommending Mass prescribing
interventions vaccines that are harming
young people's hearts and again this is
not this is not everyone it's still if
we're talking about risk ratios it's
something like one in two thousand one
in three thousand risk of myocarditis
and young people so you know so if you
got 10 people together and you know they
all got the vaccine I would bet that
none of them got myocarditis because
it's it's a very small number but when
you multiply that on a population level
suddenly you end up with hundreds and
hundreds and thousands thousands of
cases of of of cardiac injuries that
were absolutely uncalled for and were
not at all needed for for the risk of
the virus see I I agree with you on that
I think there's a slight danger when
we're having this conversation is that
we talk about the vaccine and the
reality is there are lots of vaccine
shots there was a Johnson and Johnson
there was an AstraZeneca There Was You
know the Pfizer shot and some of these
use different Technologies so can you
tell us a little bit about each shot for
instance the AstraZeneca was withdrawn
do we know which ones were more
dangerous or problematic which ones were
safer for certain types of people Etc
yeah yeah so Johnson Johnson was pulled
for for blood clots AstraZeneca was also
pulled for for certain side effects um I
can't remember which one that one is for
um early on
um I think it was I think it might have
also been blood clots but there there's
some interesting data by Dr Christina
Bell she's a Danish researcher and Dr
Martin koldorf a colleague of Dr Jay
bhattacharya he did this he's one of the
foremost Premier vaccine safety experts
and he did an interesting uh you know
analysis of the different coveted
vaccines and what you know what the um
the overall findings are and you know he
in in his analysis he's shown and then
this is from
um this Danish researcher studies
showing that the adenovirus vector
vaccines the AstraZeneca Johnson Johnson
um as well as some of the other ones
they um they did decrease overall
mortality to some degree but the MRNA
vaccines did not they did not decrease
overall mortality and they did slightly
increase
um cardiovascular issues but there's
still some confusion there's a lot
that's that's unknown at this point on
on who actually legitimately needed the
vaccine and how much
um you know their lifespan was prolonged
or reduced potentially
um but what's clear you know Martin
coldorth has done great work on this is
that the the MRNA vaccines
um the the adverse event rate it was one
in 800 and this is from a study
published in vaccine by Dr Freeman Dr
sander Greenland who's one of the
foremost International
biostatitians in the United States
um Dr Kaplan Dr Peter Doshi they
published this paper in vaccine uh last
year re-analyzing the initial Pfizer and
moderna safety trials and looking at
serious adverse event rates and they
found an adverse event rate of 1 in 800
for the trials combined Pfizer and
moderna and that is orders of magnitude
higher than any other vaccine that we've
ever seen according to their analysis
most other vaccines on the market are on
the scale of one or two per million for
serious adverse event rates and
previously vaccines have been pulled for
adverse event rates far uh far lower
than what we're seeing with these
vaccines like the 1976 swine flu vaccine
was pulled for a one in one hundred
thousand uh serious adverse event rate
these vaccines according to this
analysis are one in 800 and that and
that's not just myocarditis it's
menstrual irregularities it's blood
clots certain autoimmune issues there's
been some new reporting on potential
retinal issues with eyes and whatnot
from the vaccine but but that that is
the overall finding is a one in 800 risk
and according to their uh research
findings the overall serious adverse
event rate from the vaccine surpasses
the reduction in hospitalizations from
covid as a result of getting the vaccine
so on a cost-benefit analysis they found
that the vaccines actually cause more
harm than benefit but we they didn't
have age specific data from Pfizer
moderna so it could it could be the case
and it might be likely you know
depending on who you talk to that the
vaccines on net for everyone over 60
could be net beneficial for that age
group but for as you go lower down the
the age demographic it's seems very very
likely according to this Rock Solid
study that the vaccines could have been
potentially net harmful for at least
healthy people in their 20s 30s and 40s
meaning that
it's it's not that people are dropping
debt everywhere from the vaccine or you
know that people are getting cancer from
the vaccine but that on net if you look
at how many people were protected from
the vaccine you know let's say people
healthy people in their 20s and 30s the
actual rate of vaccine injuries would be
higher than the reduction in serious
covid outcomes and so that that study
and all the myocarditis you know data
points that I mean paint a very
disturbing uh picture on what's been
going on with these vaccines and again I
mean I I you know I'm talking to you
guys about this and I there's part of me
that thinks like Rob are you right about
this is this conspiracy theory is this
just insanity but it's like no these are
peer-reviewed studies done by the top
vaccine safety experts and I mentioned
uh Martin cold or if he did analysis
then of you know the study and I've been
looking at the sources for
um you know vaccine safety and he's
further you know confirmed that yes
these these findings are fairly rock
solid there's more research to be done
on and we're waiting on on a few studies
like we're waiting on Pfizer moderna to
release their FDA mandated studies on
subclinical myocarditis so myocarditis
rates that aren't you know falling under
the official clinical diagnosis but are
subclinical meaning
um you know young people who have
elevated troponin levels heart
palpitations shortness of breath from
the vaccine that isn't clinical but is
subclinical and could have certain
long-term implications for
um you know long-term you know cardiac
health and subclinical means that it
doesn't need a clinical intervention it
just needs monitoring yeah well
depending on where you're at so some
subclinical would mean yes monitoring
just rest others could mean you know
certain kinds of medications
um that you'd have to take the standard
intervention for myocarditis has been uh
two to three months no physical activity
even you know walking
um downstairs quickly is
um you know it's recommended not to to
do those kind of things and then taking
a variety of different medications to
um mitigate some of the the side effects
from from the vaccine
um so yeah that's right so you mentioned
the voice in your head that says is this
conspiracy am I right and I I think we
all have that voice to some extent
because these are serious issues that
we're talking about and I wouldn't want
people to come on our show or to go on
other big shows and talk about this
stuff in a way that's uh unconstructive
yeah but what you were doing it seems to
me and people can go and check out all
the studies that you're referring to
absolutely is applying what is actually
the scientific method Goods to what
we're talking about here because
I was never one of these people that
thought the vaccine is unsafe but I also
never thought that it was safe in the
sense that no medical intervention is a
hundred percent foolproof and so it
seems to me it behooves people to find
out exactly what the risk benefit is for
different groups and then prescribe that
medical intervention on the basis of the
trade-offs that we know to apply to
those groups now people will say it was
an emergency which I think is
understandable actually when you've got
a global pandemic you might accept a
risk profile that's different but what
you're talking about is something that
troubled me at the time which is why was
this pushed on everybody
and I'm curious to hear your answer on
that because there are people who say
well there's the profit motive you know
it made sense for the for the
pharmacological companies to push this
out and get as many people to take it as
possible that implies the people at
those companies were prepared for people
to die as a result or you know be
injured as a result of these things
being pushed which is a serious
allegation actually
um there's also the potential
explanation which I am leaning to in
addition to the project from profit
modes of being involved is
Public Health
it's it it's not compatible with truth
if you want everyone to do the thing you
want them to do which is what public
health kind of is it or at least became
during covet you can't then go out and
go on CNN when people have got five
minutes a day and be like well you
should take this vaccine but it might
give you heart problems a lot of people
are gonna not take it right so where do
you think this comes from the the fact
that these vaccines which had some
potential risks were pushed on people
who according to the research that
you're talking about didn't need them
and in fact may have on on average been
it may have been detrimental for them to
take those shots yeah I mean it's hard
to get into the motives area because
this is where it's very controversial
because it's hard to get into these
people that's why I'm asking it yeah
well unfortunately I don't have any any
Mind Tricks here I can't read you know
fauci's mind or Rashad volensky I mean
the the scale of you know what happened
there's been there's so many Revelations
even recently of in early 2020 one um
there's these leaked emails from a
freedom of information request where
Rachelle valensky is asking Francis
Collins and a couple of other people
about uh the phenomenon of breakthrough
cases of coven so this is about January
February 2021 they in the email she's
acknowledging that there are
breakthrough cases
um of covid meaning that people have
gotten the vaccine yet they're still
getting um covet after the point she's
acknowledging that yet February March
April May June she's going on CNN MSNBC
um and this is the head of the CDC
Rachelle wolinsky and saying you get
this virus you become a dead end it
halts transmission when you knew a few
months ago this was not the case and
then there's other things like in I
believe March or April the
um Rochelle wolinsky the head of the CDC
said we've looked across millions of
cases of this vaccine being distributed
and we haven't found a myocarditis
signal we've looked rigorously but we
haven't found one and then later on they
finally acknowledged it but at that
point you know it was clear that there
was a signal going on if you were
looking at the US Military and Israel
and so all of these things make it you
know just very difficult not to go to
certain areas which I would consider
conspiracy it's like what like what
really went on there you knew that the
vaccines weren't stopping transmission
we didn't know it was safe
um so what you know what was really
going on and you know I'm inclined to
believe some of the profit
um incentives they're all the there are
the political Dynamics as well you know
when remember most people may not
remember but
um you know before Biden got elected it
was Trump pushing the vaccine under
operation warp speed trying to you know
push FDA to approve this vaccine as soon
as possible because Trump's a politician
and he wanted everyone to get the Trump
vaccine as soon as possible to my
vaccine get the shots everyone you know
that was the whole narrative for him and
at that time you know Kamala Harris Joe
Biden even guys like Peter hotez if you
rewind the tape they were saying well
this vaccine is being approved far too
prematurely there could be safety
concerns you know we're not exactly sure
about long-term efficacy we should be
very very careful Trump is being being
you know reckless in pushing this
vaccine so early and then you know Trump
loses Biden gets elected and then
suddenly everyone Eric topel Peter Hotes
Kamala Harris all these people suddenly
move towards well now you have to get
the vaccine and if you don't get the
vaccine then you're a right-wing loony
to an idiot who doesn't know what he's
talking about and we'll make your second
class it doesn't Yeah Yeah well yeah
exactly
um so I mean there's a product there's
the profit incentives there's the you
know the political side of things which
which is very surprising still because
you know it was always the left that was
opposed to Big Pharma most you know
vigorously yet the the political
landscape to me is so confusing and you
know I don't have as many years as you
guys do um so I mean I haven't seen
historically what's going on
um no but this is this is the thing
that's happening right now and you
pointed out the left one when I was your
age uh I definitely would have
considered myself unless in many ways
many of My Views are still in the left
now but but the whole Narrative of the
left it was for the ordinary person
against big Pharma big government big
corporations and now these very same
people are pro-big Farmer they they
support Banks canceling individuals
accounts for having the wrong opinions
and they want the government to control
as much of your life as possible it's an
extraordinary transformation that has
happened in about seven years literally
and and you would have observed it even
though you're quite young it's happened
in the last few years and it is
remarkable yeah it really is I mean it's
it's it's actually not that hard to
think about you know what those people
believe people who are on the
authoritarian side I mean the line
between you know defending Free Speech
depending defending freedom and becoming
authoritarian is not as big as people
think it is I mean it's not that hard to
actually get there I mean you just
change a couple variables there's some
people have talked about hypotheticals
but it's like you know and in many
people's minds and there were some
surveys early on during covid where you
pulled people like how many people are
dying of this thing who's dying in this
thing and it's like early on there were
polls showing well two percent of people
are dying three percent of people are
dying which are by the way those are
appalling figures if that was true but
it was always point zero zero one
percent point zero three percent
something like that with a sharp age
gradient and then they racialized it as
well because more people of color were
dying from it and then that became and
then the debate became more toxic yeah
exactly yeah yeah race got involved in
it
um and so you know if that was true if
you know it's again it's not that hard
to picture what these people were
thinking you know many people in the
public who became tyrants overnight
right they're looking oh my God maybe
four percent of people are dying of
covid oh my God this is a threat to me
not just Grandma but actually you know
to young people as well and here's a
vaccine that you know is being
recommended by CDC and FDA I mean why
wouldn't you trust them right like what
you know what do I know about
epidemiology or Immunology in the same
way and this has been kind of a
fundamental error on many people's Parts
um is and then this is understandable
but it's been an error nonetheless is
treating the FDA the CDC Pfizer moderna
you know like you would similarly treat
your dentist right you go to your
dentist and I I never protest or or now
I'm thinking maybe I should question a
little more but I just got dental work
done recently it's like I don't like
question my dentist and be hyper
skeptical about oh well you know is this
actually really safe or pulling out this
cavity or you know what what kind of
um treatments am I getting for my teeth
I mean what's really going on there I
just kind of trust you know my dentist
but you know covid has revealed you know
the fallibility of many of these experts
I mean even like my family doctor for
for example and this kind of ties into
some of my newer work to some degree is
like you know I go to my family doctor
and I'm someone who's struggled with a
lot of mental health you know issues as
many people have things like ADHD
chronic anxiety chronic pain
certain kind of depressive symptoms as
well it's like go to my you know go to
my family doctor or go to psychiatrist
which is you know the societally
approved you know Pathway to get healing
and treatment for whatever issues I'm
experiencing and I'm actually not being
served what I need right I go to my
doctor here's some pills for your
anxiety here's some ADHD medications you
know here's some stimulants because you
can't focus right which if anyone knows
ADHD which is being there's some
interesting discussions about it being
over diagnosed but someone living with
very very strong ADHD it's very very
hard to focus and to actually kind of
stay in reality and stay grounded in
kind of what's happening in the present
moment and not get too lost in my head
but for these very complex psychological
spiritual you know intergenerational
issues the the simplistic answer and
solution
um is you know here's medications here's
something you can take to feel better
rather than
what's your lifestyle like what kind of
traumas have you lived through you know
you know what what are your parents like
how have they treated you um what's your
relationship to your mom and you know
how are you dealing with emotions and
stress are you actually being open to
you know stressful circumstances or are
you closing yourself in I mean this is
something that I've it's interesting the
way this kind of personal Journey that
I'm on
um which I've been kind of careful and
not sharing too too much and potentially
in a few years I might have something to
share about kind of what's been going on
but I've been on this personal Journey
towards finding truth and healing in
myself and overcoming various traumas
nothing extreme nothing violent or crazy
but just
um you know certain internal issues that
I've been grappling with and realizing
that the the the mainstream answer
whether it's scientific or even kind of
sort of
religious is not actually what exactly I
need but it's deep introspection and
um understanding of kind of where my
roots are
um understanding kind of how I came to
be where I am and you know doing various
kind of therapies
um there's I've been taking interest in
psychedelic therapy is very interesting
which is not kind of promoted by the big
Pharma side of things but there's a
whole world of you know Mind Body
um uh connection understanding how
trauma is stored in the body and how we
can actually overcome it and the big
Pharma solution just Falls so
dramatically short that it's it's it's
Preposterous that we're actively
medicating a whole generation
increasingly with again ADHD depression
there's Now The ozempic Craze the new
weight loss drug is being promoted FDA
approved ozempic or semi-glutide with
Govi there's all these Alternatives
that's being pushed now for people who
are very you know obese and overweight
as a solution to of their problems and
now it's kind of coming out more and
more there's an article in CNN a couple
days ago about how people are having
stomach paralysis severe
gastrointestinal issues from taking this
weight loss drug include including I
think it was
um Amy Schumer comedian I think who
talked about her unpleasant experiences
but in my mind we're we're moving so far
away from kind of the source kind of the
basics of you know emotions and you know
the basics of you know healthy diets you
know eating well exercising we're moving
away from that and just medicating and
vaccinating our way through everything
and not being honest about again going
back to covid like who's actually at
risk it's overwhelmingly obese people
and in the U.S the UK and Canada to a
lesser extent obesity is absolutely an
epidemic in the U.S 40 of people are
obese 10 of the population are severely
obese meaning they have a hard time
moving around right there those people
are incredibly vulnerable to the flu to
covid diabetes a whole host of issues
and the solution to that I mean I mean
again for some people it may make sense
to you know get the vaccine but the
solution to that is losing weight eating
healthy addressing traumas addressing
you know why certain people are
experiencing debilitating you know
anxiety problems or depression ADHD I
mean there's a lot of nuance to that
conversation that's being completely
missed by the the mainstream narrative
whether it's covid whether it's mental
health we're all I think moving away
from from you know the source and kind
of basic
Simple Solutions that are actually
taking into account the complexity of
human beings and not just putting a
Band-Aid mRNA vaccine or ADHD medication
on top of a whole host of personal and
systemic issues in the way that we deal
with health and the way we deal with
mental health problems you know it's
such a profound point that what you're
saying because I remember during the
pandemic you know little things like you
know if you have dark if you have more
melanin in your skin if you have darker
skin it's a good idea to take a vitamin
D supplement because if you've got low
vitamin D levels you're not going to
react well to covid if you are obese you
know you need to lose weight because
you're going to you you're going to be
at more at risk of the virus but we
weren't told that
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
I guess the question that I really want
to ask now is do you know how many
people have died from the vaccine how
many people have been seriously injured
how many people are in line to get
compensation from their injuries as a
result of these of these vaccines yeah
so for covid personally I don't know
anyone who's died of covid
um and I've you know grandparents
um they got vaccinated and I encourage
them you know to get the shots in
retrospect it's still it's so much is
unclear right the vaccines were approved
under emergency use authorization right
they did not have Decades of testing so
there's still so many questions right
and an emergency situation is very
difficult and you have to make these
pressing decisions on what to do
um as a public health
um uh Institution
um but you know obviously people died of
covet I don't I don't know of any
personally
um again it doesn't mean that didn't I
want to be very very clear there's
always a voice in my head when I'm
talking about this that's like is this
conspiracy or is this real and it's like
no no I I think what what you should say
is I I don't think how many people you
know who have died of code is
particularly relevant to this yeah we
know quite a lot of people died of
covert we also know that quite a lot of
people died with covid and were
registered as having died off covet I
mean my aunt died of covid but she had a
stroke and had to be transported to
hospital in an ambulance got their
unconscious she was there for a few days
picked up covered and died of covid I
think she was going to struggle anyway
with respect so there was a lot of those
cases however a lot of people did die of
covered I don't think any of us would
want to misrepresent that but how many
people I think Francis question is how
many people do we know how many people
have been injured by vaccines how many
people have have died as a result yeah
well to finish the loop on I mean the
best data that we have is that among the
overall death tolls in the U.S about 1.2
million people have died of covid right
from that you know total number it's not
all from covid it's about 30 to 40
percent of those cases are absolutely
incidental and some of those cases that
are logged in as from covid are actually
suicides and homicides uh Justin Hart on
substack is as logged some of those CDC
cases that well you know people die of a
suicide test positive for covid and
again it's like I look at that I'm like
please tell me that's wrong please tell
me that that is someone can debunk that
as misinformation
it was happening in this country as well
yeah yeah and then there's all the
people again who um if you looked at the
average
um uh you know age of people dying of
covet and what their health was it was
like the average person dying of covet
had three to four comorbidities right
and in the icus you know 70 to 80
percent of people severely obese
deficient vitamin D multiple you know
comorbidities right those were people
that we you know really should have
focused on not people like myself or
people like yourself
a borderline case yeah
uh so vaccine injuries vaccine injuries
um again the the number of vaccine
injuries we don't really know there's
more and more data coming out there's a
recent study in South Korea that proved
beyond the doubt and we already kind of
knew this but this study really
concretizes that there are you know
potentially hundreds or thousands of
people that did die from the vaccine
from Sudden cardiac arrest from from any
kind of cardiac complication that we
don't really know because autopsies
aren't regularly done and so in South
Korea they were looking at every you
know every case of vaccine injury
because of their the way their health
care is designed and they were closely
tracking
um the vaccine injuries and and
specifically on the the cardiac front
and they found a very high rate of
myocarditis which we already you know
knew but they also found many many
people who had died from the vaccine
vaccine I think they only found
um well only is is not the right word
but I think they officially approved
something like eight
cases of uh vaccine-induced deaths
related to cardiac issues and that's
only the eight is only out of about I
think it was 60 to 70 percent of their
population used mrnas
um and they and their population you
know was smaller and they excluded a
number of cases that they weren't sure
about so there were a bunch of other you
know deaths after the vaccine where they
couldn't tell a lot of these issues are
very very difficult but at the very
least
there were there are globally there's
cases in Canada and the U.S where people
did die from the vaccine
um healthy you know young people that
number on an absolute level is very very
small people aren't you know dropping
dead like flies everywhere but it did
happen and it happened as a result of
the complete failure on the part of
Public Health to be honest about again
who this product was for and who had
benefited it was completely reckless in
the way that we you know imposed you
know these vaccines and injured so many
people as a result of that many people
still dealing with
um their injuries last year do you know
how many people
well I mean it's impossible to know how
many people I mean you said so many
people so you must have a ballpark
figure in your head yeah well so the
study I mentioned earlier one in 800 is
the rate that is by far the the most
dangerous vaccine we've ever seen if
that study is Right publishing vaccine
by Leading researchers from Stanford
UCLA and University of Maryland people
can go look it up I actually have the
author on my podcast and I grilled them
for like four hours trying to find holes
in his study of like maybe you did this
wrong maybe this was wrong and I
couldn't find any no one is willing to
debate him he's tried um this is Dr
Joseph Raymond one of the lead authors
of the study but that alone the fact
that you know the one in 800 rate this
being the most dangerous widespread
pharmaceutical intervention that's been
released to the public is incredibly
scary Eerie ominous like it's this is
what drives a lot of the the conspiracy
thinking is things like that because
when you when you've done you know so
much harm and you've not been honest
you've not been transparent about the
risks people are going to question your
reputation and what you actually care
about and I'm not even willing to go to
some of the darker places that some of
my friends do
um and I'm not even like against that
like there's so much that I don't know
but there are people that you know
believe that there were people who
wanted to kill people or you know you
know did want to harm others
um to me that's not likely to me there's
there's a lot of kind of you know love
and compassion driven by extreme
psychotic fear right people who are
really really afraid and and genuinely
wanted you know good for me and good for
you like so many people are dying of
covid here's an intervention just like
you go to your dentist or your family
doc and you get your blood work done
this mRNA vaccine is the solution to our
problems we don't want people dying so
everyone should get this thing and it's
it's out of this deep
I mean in many cases it is out of a deep
love and compassion for other people
like we want people to be alive we don't
want people to to die from this thing
but you know love and compassion is nice
but when it's driven by this extreme
fear and this complete
um you know disparity between you know
reality and what's being presented in
the media and and we and we know this
you know in my experience in the past
with BLM and police shootings right and
this is something that I I covered
heavily at the time and at that time
many of the people that I'm now very
uh displeased with and how they respond
to kovid you know were aware of the the
uh the the the major difference between
what was being presented on say police
shootings and what was actually
happening right if you pull people on
how many unarmed you know black citizens
are dying from police shootings you know
they they if especially if you pull
liberal people or very liberal people
they they overestimate that number by
10x 50x 100x they think it's happening
all the time they don't actually know
what the facts are and same with with
kovid many people who we can talk about
this more and more you know many people
who I thought and who I still believe
are very reasonable and who I thought
um would be very rational and and sober
minded in their approach actually
completely you know fell short I mean
there was
sorry yeah let me just stop you there
because
I think what we're doing here is we're
also missing a part of the argument and
the part of the argument is that the
umbrella term of long covid in that we
don't know what the long-term effects of
covert are going to be there have been
people who have had covid and it has
ruined their lives to be brutally honest
they have developed symptoms which means
that they're not being able to work that
their activities that their way of life
has been severely curtailed and what
some people will say and I put this
question to you now is hang on we
brought in these vaccines because okay
you're not you may not die from covid
but there are potential long-term side
effects so nobody in the medical
community knows because this is a new
virus and this is one way to ensure that
you may not develop long covered
do you see what I mean yeah you're
saying the claim that the vaccines
protect against
or or reduce the chances of developing
long covered symptoms such as chronic
fatigue such as you know vascular
vascular conditions etc etc yeah I mean
long covet is very complex and it's
there's been a few studies done Dr Marty
McCary has written about this Johns
Hopkins researcher uh uh at the Wall
Street Journal looking at the best
studies on long covid and there's no
clear indication of you know infection
versus getting long coveted and that the
best correlate that they found is people
who are prone towards wait for it
anxiety psychosomatic issues people more
prone to to worrying to overthinking
things and this is something that I've
tracked kind of in my own life as
someone who actually suffers from Mind
Body issues as they call it or
psychosomatic issues meaning you
experience symptoms in your body whether
digestive issues chronic pains and very
various areas tendinitis and it's not
actually caused by anything structural
but it's caused by deep-rooted fears and
anxieties there's this this fast
literature that's being um
Advanced more and more there's a great
book the way out by Dr Alan Gordon an
expert in in chronic pain and
psychosomatic issues right many people
who struggle with debilitating fear and
anxiety have severe digestive issues
tendonitis back pain is one of the most
common ones and the solution to their
problem is not back surgery or
physiotherapy
or you know medications for the
digestion but it's actually to reprogram
it the way reprogrammed the way they
perceive fear and the way that they
perceive
stressful situations in life and a lot
of that is due to you know traumatic
experiences and you know behavioral
conditioning from parents right if you
have parents who you know freak out very
quickly and are very stressed out then
you know children are going to be more
prone towards
experiencing reality in that same way
and experiencing these issues so so long
covered I'm I'm basically entirely
convinced is psychosomatic is a
psychosomatic phenomenon meaning it's
for most people who are experiencing
symptoms for weeks and weeks and months
on end
did some of the root causes are actually
psychological rather than than physical
but again there's so much that we don't
know there's a lot of research that we
that we still need there was one study
that I I should look deeper into but
there was one study in France I believe
where they looked at long covid and they
they looked for antibodies and they
found that actually a lot of people said
they had long covid but they actually
um you know they weren't infected at
that point or they were infected a long
time ago or they had lower or higher
antibodies like it really kind of
um spread you know spread across the
Spectrum there was no clear like these
people had really bad covet or these
people had covered recently and they
have long coveted versus people who
hired a while ago I mean there's there's
a lot of complexity there but but I'm
fairly convinced that it's a kind of a
psychosomatic disorder well Rob we could
talk for a lot longer and we will on
locals but we have to wrap up here and
ask you a final question uh in this
section of the interview which is of
course as always are you vaccinated I
uh what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that you
think really should be yeah yeah there's
many many directions I could I could go
in um I mean
there are some spiritual and kind of
psychological things that I'm I'm really
tracking um in my own life when it comes
to you know religion and the importance
of that
um
I would say one of the things that we're
not
acknowledging enough or something that
I've been very very surprised by and I'm
now thinking more and more about is to
go back to our whole conversation about
how so many uh and when we can talk more
about this on locals if you want but how
so many reasonable people so many
rational people are capable of becoming
completely misled authoritarian in some
cases
um and you know being quite delusional
about what's going on and then actively
spreading you know misinformation and
there's one example if we can spend a
minute if you want one example of
um it was Sam Harris on your podcast and
you came on and you know that whole
interview went viral which is very
interesting
um but after on your on your locals page
where you were talking about
um covid well I said it at the time
people freaked out about what he said
about uh Trump and Biden actually for me
the more controversial stuff was said on
the locals that when we were talking
about of it yeah yeah and so that that
for me has been you know very so to take
it to a quick step back you know again
being an open-minded person going into
covet and looking at you know what's
really going on you know many places
that I would expect to be rational and
so reminded about covid actually were
very very delusional I mean there was
the Colette phenomenon which I've
written for Colette I have great respect
for Claire I think she's lovely and
she's a great person but at the time you
know Claire was writing like these are
the safest vaccines we've ever seen in
Colette it's like what the hell are you
talking about at that point
at best we didn't know there were
suspicions to think that was wrong you
at that point there was not enough
safety testing on you know on efficacy
and at that point it wasn't clear about
myocarditis to actually make those
claims
um and that's been Vindicated now with
you know some of the best research
showing that these are again the most
dangerous vaccines we've seen in history
but then you have Sam Harris on your
show who I've utmost respect for like
you Francis I I use his waking up his
waking up app every day and recommended
to anyone you know really struggling
with uh mental health issues and
interested in kind of deeper spiritual
concerns but he came on your podcast and
you guys are talking about covid and you
asked him about you know the vaccines
and all the the disagreements with him
and Brad and Joe Rogan and all this
stuff and he told you guys you know
whatever danger you're going to put on
the side of the vaccine there's more
danger with covid and for virtually all
age cohorts
um the vaccine does not pose any
significant danger kovid poses more
danger and it's like that is all
completely wrong that is all false
there's no evidence to suggest that that
is true and I've told him I've told him
this personally as an admirer of his
um and I'm not going to reveal you know
a private communication but you know
I've went to him personally and said hey
I love you man I've you've taught me how
to think and you're someone that I go to
for a reasonable
um you know interesting takes on on
complex topics but this was you know
completely wrong like you can't make
statements this Broad and sweeping and
simplistic as you know whatever Danger's
on on the side of covet it's vaccines
are more dangerous it's like for who
first of all for who are we are you
talking about my you know 65 year old
you know diabetic obese Grandpa are we
talking about me and the the best
research again shows that that is
absolutely not the case on a population
level but people like Harris and you
know Colette Claire Lehman
um and and many people
um in this alternative space that kind
of become isolated and have you know
kind of moved away from some of the
contrarianism they I mean they on on
covet it's been very surprising how they
really kind of fell off their horse and
became unreasonable and delusional and
and it's in some ways it's not that
surprising given who they were trusting
so someone like Sam you know his sources
were you know Dr Eric tople Dr Nicholas
christakis and to some extent you know
perhaps the CEC or the FDA but those
scientists got so many things wrong
right Nicholas christakis from Yale you
know he was supporting vaccine mandates
he thought one percent of people were
dying from covid when the rate was Far
lower people like Jay bhattacharya and
Martin koldorf they were far more in
line with
um the the most accurate and compelling
research on covid then those people were
and still at this point you're you're
not seeing the level of transparency and
honesty that I would respect from some
of these people right and I I suspect
that some of that will come around you
know to some degree and there is a
problem of the whole RFK Junior
phenomenon and you know vaccines causing
autism and there's a lot of
there's a lot that I don't know and
there's a lot that I know is [__]
you know when it comes to uh conspiracy
theories on vaccines and 5G and Wi-Fi
whatever but I've just been amazed at
how many you know reasonable trustworthy
people on covid you know just
became completely delusional about what
was going on and have actually failed to
live up to their principles of free
speech and you know figuring things out
through conversation I mean that was
always Sam Harris's thing right it was
about all you have is conversation and
that's what made someone like Sam Harris
so
um respected and you know revered by you
know young intellectuals and thinkers
like myself was like he'll go into the
ring with you know a
uh Muslim or Christian evangelist or a
black lives matter supporter
um and talk about well this is what's
actually going on and never being like
well I'm not the expert I can I can't
talk about this people like Harris the
approach was always like we can use our
our reason and
um you know our cognitive faculty is to
actually come to some ground truths
about what's going on but on covid it
was this complete reversal from you know
engaging in conversation to well I'm not
the expert default to the experts but at
the same time these vaccines are really
safe and effective and whatever dangers
on covid you know the vaccines are far
less you know dangerous and everyone
should get it
um versus you know I hate I hate I think
I think uh there are a lot of people who
got carried away for some of the reasons
that you mentioned I mean fear is one of
them and uh I don't know uh about Claire
or Sam and and friends and family or
whatever there may have been family of
friends who have you know compromised or
whatever yeah
um I think I I agree with you obviously
you know what we thought about the whole
thing but I also think we particularly
with people like Sam and Claire who've
made a really big contribution yes also
to the way that we have conversations I
really respect them both even though
we've had our disagreements and whatever
there has to be a way for people to be
able to
disagree but also to get things wrong
and to recover from that and we live in
an internet age where that increasingly
doesn't happen so one of the things I'm
Keen to hold out for both Sam and Claire
is is an opportunity to to go okay well
look we disagreed about that particular
thing and it was a really important
thing that we disagreed about
and yet you're still someone of value
you're still someone with interesting
ideas you're still someone who's welcome
in the fold of you know the heterodox
conversations and maybe you know I know
for example Claire blocked me on Twitter
because I criticized her over covid and
later she unblocked me and apologize you
know people can can come back from
things as well and I think that's
important to hold out as a
as a thing that we all aspire to at
least yeah because you're gonna get
you're 23 years old you're going to get
things wrong believe me 22. even worse
yeah you've got you've got a lot of time
to get a lot of [__] wrong I can tell
you from my experience we've got things
wrong everybody's going to make mistakes
no matter how smart you are no matter
how principled you are sometimes you do
the thing that you think is the right
thing but you were reacting emotionally
or whatever and everyone's got their
buttons everybody yeah so uh I hear you
I actually agree with you on these two
particular people but I also think we
really have to try to create a space
where people can come back uh people
like absolutely people can change their
mind people can can be welcomed back and
you know for both Sam and Claire I wish
them nothing but the best and I really
hope that they continue to make the
contribution they've been making today
in this in these conversations yeah yeah
we want to extend love and grace yeah
and acknowledge that we're all humans
and there and this is you know this this
is why I think many people should stick
to kind of what they really know like I
never talk about climate change I don't
talk about Ukraine Russia I know you do
Constantine I think I saw your debate
with Dave Smith very very interesting
and I still don't know what exactly is
right
of course
but it's like there's so much that we
don't know and I guarantee with
absolutely everyone listening to this
there are things that we are doing that
we know that that we don't know are
wrong you know yeah and then this is
from covet on like what kind of water
are we drinking what kind of shoes
you're wearing you know what kind of
Health monitoring devices you should use
which medications which therapies you
should do is it you know veganism versus
carnivore I mean I got friends all
across the Spectrum you know advocating
for their specific diet and their
supplements to you know work through
their particular health problems there's
a lot that everyone you know is getting
wrong and that we are ultimately
fallible and you know we have our
limited capacities so we have to be able
you know on our part as if we're talking
about covid certain things that have
been Vindicated we have to be able to
extend grace and mercy and love to
people that did get some things very
wrong but then there is that question
um of like you know you know to what
point when someone is so
um so you know still grasping on to what
they believe to be true and not you know
showing any signs of humility it becomes
more and more difficult and it's you
know for me the love is still there
always for people that that got things
wrong and
um you know were were unreasonable in
many ways but at the same time the clock
is ticking and the responsibility is you
know is on them for saying hey I got
this wrong you know I was wrong to you
know say that these vaccines were so
safe and safer you know than covid for
everyone
um you know you have to admit that and
actually concede that those you know
errors were made and you don't actually
have to go all the way I think that's
some of the fear there's some kind of
egoic attachment to well if I say that
well then you know then I have to say
Ivermectin you know super effective for
everyone and vaccines are killing
everyone and vaccines cause autism it's
like no no there is a middle way to
actually taking this there is a course
you can take where you don't have to go
down the conspiracy route you don't have
to actually you know believe things that
are not true but there is a need for
humility and on covet unfortunately
again many reasonable people kind of
fell off their horse and were wrong to
trust very fallible and wrong experts
like Eric tople Peter Hotes the CDC the
FDA the federal governments they got
that you know miserably wrong and there
is an opportunity to come back from that
and to acknowledge the the big mistakes
that were made oh great head on over to
locals where we continue the
conversation with your questions
what's the most effective way and you're
actually quite good at this I will say
this to communicate with someone when
you happen to be from a different
ideological divide or you're challenging
the current consensus narrative
[Music]